Well,
she was about to be an intern working at NASA and she was like,
here it is.
Everyone shut the fuck up.
I got accepted for a NASA internship and look,
he writes language,
she says suck my Dick and balls.
I'm working at NASA and he says that I'm on the National Space Council that
oversees NASA.
Oh dear.
Funny.
First of all,
that shit is funny.
Suck my dick and balls and it's a girl.
Second of all,
we didn't even go to the fucking moon.
The moon.
I saw you talking about that.
Yeah,
no I I,
well I could,
I could be convinced.
I was convinced that we didn't for a long time.
Now I'm convinced I have no fucking idea.
Yeah,
I don't really,
I it's,
I,
I don't think we went to the moon.
It makes you think off of base.
It's not rooted in science.
How much,
how much have you really paid attention to it?
Cause I went down the rabbit hole.
I go many,
many years ago.
I've kind of like,
it's always like the social kind of where there's smoke,
there's fire type pools of just like,
you know,
us being in a race in no country is coming second.
Uh,
you know,
other space programs not catching up to 19,
what,
69,
1969,
1972,
uh,
American technology.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like,
uh,
every time we went was under the Nixon administration.
That's a good one.
Uh,
these types of little things that just make you go and I'll probably like it
did,
you know,
like a flat earth there,
but it was the conference.
You ever watched the press conference when they returned from the moon?
Uh,
no.
Wait,
what's the,
what's the clue in there or what's the suspicious thing?
They look super depressed.
They look super deceptive.
They look fidgety and,
uh,
they're,
they're talking weird and they're saying shit.
They refute later.
One of the things they said,
Michael Collins,
who's actually never,
he's supposed to be in,
he'd never landed on the surface of the moon.
Buzz Aldrin and Neil Armstrong did,
he stayed up in the orbiter.
And,
uh,
they were,
they were asking about stars and he said,
I'm no,
I don't recall seeing any stars.
And then years later he wrote in his book about how magnificent stars look.
There's a lot of that shit.
But the press,
we see that if you want,
and this doesn't mean anything,
I'm not a cop.
But if I was a cop and I was interviewing them,
I'd be like,
these motherfuckers are guilty.
Something is wrong here.
Like they seem like guilty people.
Then you could look,
you don't get say,
hey man,
they were probably psychologically distressed.
They were probably dealing with the,
the,
the pressure of having come back from the moon and all this fame that they had
never experienced their whole life.
They're not there.
Their astronauts,
they're scientists.
And now all of a sudden they're standing in front of all these people and
everyone's asking them questions and they feel super nervous.
But Nah,
these niggas was lying.
Maybe tell you everybody,
my favorite thing is when you,
when,
uh,
cause I'll say it very casually.
If people become like,
you know,
patriots and rocket science,
this is what,
it's all you like how we went.
I'm like,
you don't know either.
We shit is bullshit because it wasn't you and it wasn't me.
Let's stop with that.
So we probably lied about it and we live better than any other country on earth
and I'm proud of that.
There's a lot of weird shit with the fit video footage.
There's a lot of footage where it looks like they're on wires dangling from
wires and then they bounced back up from their feet in this weird way,
it looks at it being yanked up from the ground.
There's a,
there's a video where it looks like they're on trampolines is if you Google
astronauts and trampolines,
I'm not even kidding because it just looks like that.
I actually put it up,
it's a video that I found Google astronauts on trampolines as a video on youtube
and you're,
you're watching them bounce around and you're like,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Wait.
You guys are on the fucking moon and you're hiding behind the lunar module.
Like you can't see their feet.
You can't see how they're doing this,
but it looks like either they're bouncing on something or they're being yanked
up in the air,
or it's one six gravity and it's just has a weird effect on people.
But look at this,
watch this.
Like how strange is this?
See,
look,
you just lands but doesn't,
I mean,
even the way he's,
he's moving it.
It's like he's being dangled.
It's very strange to see him bouncing around.
But that also could
all this stuff.
We did it,
but we were like playing golf with bouncing around.
Like the moon landing set was built by the people who made discovery zone,
but it also could be slides.
He fell.
Boom.
It just jumped up and fell.
That's so strange.
But it also could be,
this is just what your body does at one six earth's gravity.
You know,
there's a whole bunch of,
you know it.
I'm excited to see,
uh,
this one's weird.
Someone else going back to the moon and then if it matches,
this is from a a movie.
Uh,
I forget what was the name of the movie was,
but you could watch some of the go.
They show some special effects they use in movies,
but watch some of the weird shit go a little bit further ahead of this.
Yeah,
right there.
This is some of the weird stuff where you see these guys like fall down and then
it looks like they just get yanked back up by wires.
It's very strange.
Yeah.
I mean,
but the press conferences,
yeah.
It's uh,
it's the,
it's the social aspect of it cause it's like I won't begin to know like how the
flag is supposed to look in the waving and the shadows.
And the thing that like a lot of people argue about I,
it's just the political and so it's like,
I kind of think I know when the government is lying about something,
you know what I mean?
Like the history is there.
Watch this.
What's that going to stay?
I bag up,
watch this,
watch how he gets up.
Like he'd gotten yanked up.
Oh,
there's a
bunch of those.
There's a bunch of those.
It makes it look like they're on wire pulled back up their feet.
Very strange.
But again,
have you ever been in one,
six earth gravity?
I haven't.
No.
What that maybe,
maybe it just looks fake because when you're in one,
six earth's gravity,
how movement do you think we never ever been like,
like,
uh,
my,
my conspiracy belief is specific to thinking that of man has walked around on
the surface of the more specific to that crashing,
you know,
Luna,
whatever.
I that's all 100%.
Yeah,
of course.
It's specifically man moving out.
Yeah.
It specifically that.
And you don't think anybody has ever done this?
I don't think so.
No.
In life,
like everything.
I don't think,
I mean we're the only country that would have the press conference,
some clips,
weird clips from the press conference because the press conference trip you out
and see and see just like other,
you know,
countries who have the means to do it.
Like they're an intention about going play place in this place a mess.
And go big screen.
Michael Collins.
Look how sad these guys look.
So weird.
Watch.
This was our pleasure to have dissipated in one great adventure.
It's an adventure that took place not just in the month of July,
but rather one that took place in the last decade.
We all hear and the people listening in today had the opportunity to share that
adventure over.
It's developing an unfolding
in the past months and years.
It's our privilege today to share with you
some of the details of that final month of July.
That was
certainly the highlight for the three of us of that decade.
They just went to the moon and they all looked like they just saw that data and
make it part of it.
They all liked they lions.
Neil,
it looks so fake.
But again,
that could be extreme nerves.
It can be people that don't know how to handle being in front of press.
It could be,
uh,
introverts that are forced on the camera.
It could be a lot of issues.
If you went to the moon and then you came back and,
uh,
you were sitting in that press conference,
would you be at the light?
Like what would your,
what would your actions be?
Would you be like,
Yay.
Or would you be like more like,
like it would be,
it would look like,
uh,
like,
like a lake was a press conference after they want you back.
I have my hat on some champagne just pointing to reporters.
And why didn't they bring back like a rock or something?
Then the shore,
they brought it back a lot.
It brought back many rocks,
but some of them turned out to be petrified wood.
They gave one of them too.
It's a real mystery.
Yeah.
They gave a moon rock in a
69 or 72.
Uh,
there's the Prime Minister of Holland,
whoever it was,
whatever,
whoever the person who runs Holland and a years later they analyze it and it was
petrified wood.
It was not a moon rock.
Well,
in fairness,
I do get the,
like by the time we got to Holland,
the gift basket is going to change.
It was like when I'd given away the real moon rock to Holland like that.
Like you know England gets a real moon rock.
Yeah.
France gets a little roller moon.
Right.
But they get a little,
they get a moon rock statutes skill.
Find some,
you got some dude's blocks.
Did you think about this Mars mission?
Look at it.
That's all real.
Look.
Rovers are real.
It's all the,
the technology is proven and legitimate and I don't think he'd ever fake
anything today.
Like you could fake things in 1969 if they,
I think if anything for sure what they did is it's been proven that they fake
some footage for sure.
Some photographs,
my cord it over the original again,
those little things like you recorded over the array.
Yeah.
The original in a world where even the importance of syndication was no,
I think they also lost the telemetry data,
which is like the binary hard ones and Zeros that show the distance between the
earth and lunar module at every step of the trip.
They lost it.
Yeah.
They lost that shit.
But you know,
then again,
you gotta realize like people die and people responsible for storage and no
one's paying attention and there's funding and the funding gets pulled.
And this,
this plausible reasons for some of the,
I don't know.
I mean,
there are episodes of blossom being guarded in a vault somewhere in Burbank,
episodes of blossom,
right?
You could get fucking money off of blossom.
You can't make any money off of these goddamn moon landing eclipse.
Look,
there's some people that absolutely are convinced that we didn't go,
and I used to be one of them,
and I would love if they proved that it was fake.
It would make me more happy than anything else in the world.
You know what?
Uh,
oh,
it makes me very happy to,
I the,
the thing that keeps me hone in on,
and maybe we went is a tour it NASA wants and they were nice.
Oh,
that's probably it then.
That was nice.
But you gotta realize those aren't the same people.
You know,
when people say like,
no,
but lies.
Okay.
But those were NASA from 1969 these are different humans.
Yeah.
We're talking about 48 fucking years ago.
These are completely different human beings.
They stand on the backs of liars.
Yeah.
Well there was a stocking vitalist at NASA so we can let us ask questions if
you're going to fucking lie.
What you say about the tour.
I'm like stopping by ms to NASA and allowing
us to ask questions if you're going to lie.
I don't think they think they're lying.
I don't think they're involved in,
if any,
if there was a conspiracy like safety did fake the moon landing.
No one today.
Who's alive was a part of that.
Yeah,
except Buzz Aldrin.
He's the only one still alive.
But he,
he did somebody,
he punched the dude in the face.
Punched some guy.
What did he said he barked.
See Bro partsy rural made a move.
I had dinner with them or with the guards.
See Bro.
Yeah.
Dinner with him many years ago and back when I was a full blown a moon
nonbeliever and I know I'm contacted them,
got ahold of him,
took him to dinner and a bunch of questions like that.
You use your celebrity for good
cause of the test?
Good.
No.
It was just like these real specific pockets of like people that you just want
to talk to is like,
yeah,
I want him to sniff them out through them.
You can see someone doing interviews,
you could see someone in an edited format and you kind of get a sense of who
they are.
You don't really get a sense of who they are until you actually talk to them.
Like you and him sharing a plate of pasta.
What was his like what did he,
did he give us,
give you anything and it's like gives context.
So like that moment or like just like why he did it.
Uh,
he was convinced.
He was absolutely convinced that it was a hoax and he,
what he was convinced was that there was a space race between us and Russia and
that it was,
uh,
it was essentially a militarized space race.
And what they were trying to do is prove military superiority.
If you had the,
the rockets that could get you to the moon,
your technology was superior.
And the way he framed it is like the United States had control over what was
aired.
Um,
they put it on television and no one foresaw the future.
No one foresaw that.
One day you would be looking at these clips on youtube and analyzing them and
putting them in slow Mo.
They didn't even think that that was going to be a thing
that was where that works.
Yeah.
And they were going to show it in black and white and they were going to have it
three d projected so that you would projected on a screen and then people,
uh,
who were filming it would have to film the screen.
Like they didn't even get a live feed when it was airing on television.
It was airing people filming the screen that it was being projected on some
what,
what?
Yeah.
They broke it down.
So it looked more and more a grainy and fake.
Like they,
if you were trying to do something that was not done to the technology of the
day,
they would possibly obscure some fraud.
They did it all those ways.
There's so many things that they did that you,
you would go in.
And when in terms of like conspiracies,
it's a conspiracy theorist wet dream.
Cause if it is a fake,
it's the biggest fake of all time.
And there's so many things that are squirrely about it.
There's so many things it doesn't mean it's fake.
Yeah.
But there's so many things.
So has anybody to the moon?
No.
No one's been to the moon since 1969 to 1972.
Those are the only trips they did.
Seven attempts.
Six of them successful.
Apollo 13 was the one that wasn't successful.
That was that big movie.
Um,
they landed on the moon and then came back seven times,
262,000 miles away.
Now here's where it gets crazy.
Or S plus or minus depending on where the moon's out at the time.
What's crazy is 262,000 miles pretty far.
Um,
what's crazy is
no,
my bad.
I'm thinking about,
oh that's three zeroes
cause I was like what map?
Or you see
that no other human space mission where a human has been a part of it since then
has ever gone more than 400 miles from the earth's surface.
Is that where the space station,
all the space shuttle missions,
everything,
everything inside.
It was further than 400 well 400 miles.
So the guy you had dinner with did what?
For Buzz Aldrin to sock them.
He told Buzz Aldrin he was a liar.
He said you're a liar and a crook and buzz went black pitch
popped him right in the jaw.
[inaudible] acid is a new one.
Contact him after that.
I mean,
I would imagine,
I don't know.
I don't know what he's doing in the day.
Our have it all.
But I mean immediately after.
No,
no,
no.
The Guy Bart's Hebrew.
But I mean immediately after the punch.
Is there any type of like,
I think he tried to press charges and the cops told them to go fuck off.
I think it was one of those songs.
It was,
it wasn't the best punch either.
I mean if you go to the hospital from that punch and buzz was like in his
eighties at the time,
but he tried,
he followed,
he was harassed a lot of those guys.
He harassed a lot of the astronauts and tried to get him to swear on bibles.
He'd bring a Bible and say square house wearing this Bible that you want in the
moon.
Yeah,
I mean it was,
it was a lot of,
just a lot of weird shit.
There's a another one that's a 25th anniversary of the Apollo Moon missions.
He gives a speech at the White House in front of this group of uh,
honor roll students like some of the best students in the country in near arm.
John gives us real weird fucking speech is like we have here amongst us.
You want to hear it?
If I find a,
which makes it weird,
when you'll see it,
you'll get it.
It's just real.
It doesn't mean we didn't go to the moon.
It doesn't mean,
by the way,
it's fucking weird.
It's really funny cause I presented as like,
yeah,
I don't think we went and,
and I didn't even have half of what you're getting.
Oh,
I'll give you a way more.
There's a lot.
Watch this.
You're going to watch this and held back tears as he spoke.
These brief cryptic,
this is from a funny thing happened on the way to the Moon Fartsy Bros movie,
but this is a real thing that happened today.
We had
a group of students,
it's best
to you.
We say we have only completed a beginning.
We leave you much.
That is under,
there are great ideas.
Undiscovered breakthroughs available to those who can remove one of truths,
protective layers,
what he is the flock.
Okay,
well two things that mean a little unfair to it is,
and you add that fucking walk music to anything.
Everything sells incredibly creepy,
but it's true.
But it does sound like a one of true.
Trying to tell
you can't get more cryptic.
Yeah,
and you also can't get more exciting.
It sounds like she theorists and almost kind of sounds like he's like until the
child who actually figures out how to go to the fucking moon,
they're a great breakthroughs for those who can remove one of truce protective
layers.
What would you,
what would you rather the the moon confession or the art Kelly Confession.
If you had to pick one r Kelly made a song.
Yeah,
I saw that tape.
I need that moon confession.
Yeah,
I need that movie art.
Kelly,
you,
I don't need that confession.
I'm good.
I know
now that that's up to the wall.
Now think the law's going to have a piece of that,
you know are,
Kelly seems to be pretty tough lawn,
but the moon confession would be fascinating.
I would be,
I'd be excited to,
or like a moon,
like,
I don't know,
just I guess it's not on them to prove that they went.
So I'm saying like,
you know,
just some type of like
1969 it's a different world.
Nixon's president.
I'm like,
I don't know if they did lie.
I don't know.
Yeah.
I used to think I knew like,
do you not think I know,
I mean it's foolish.
I don't know Jack Shit about astrophysics,
but I know if there wasn't like,
you know,
if there's any precedent we would guess would be down,
it'd be Trump.
He did tell us about it.
Well,
no,
I'm saying,
well,
I'm saying like I'm saying like Nixon just like it is a perfect storm of like,
oh yeah,
the time Nixon,
yeah.
Oh,
he's the most deceptive president of all time except the current one.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
it's it,
it's very interesting.
I,
I've shut down a lot of barbecues was talking about just bring it up now you
have more information.
And by the way,
this is a fraction of the shit that I,
dude,
I did research for a years.
I debated a,
a scientist on Penn Jillette's radio show about it.
How did it go?
Pretty good for me
even though I don't even agree with some of the shit that I said back.
Where does that argument end on just a agree to disagree?
It was a time constraint.
I would do it far differently now.
I think far differently now that I did that I would not take
this.
I know we didn't do it approach,
uh,
because I don't know.
We didn't do it and that's the thing.
I,
I very casually go.
Yeah,
probably not.
Yeah.
But it just,
the,
the things that don't add up to me don't add up in a way that just makes me go.
Yeah.
Do you know about the van Allen radiation belts?
You know about all that?
I not enough to like there's a,
there's a belt of radiation,
like a doughnut shaped from just years of a,
no,
no.
It's just naturally surrounds the earth.
Oh,
you know what I'm thinking about?
I'm thinking about the,
nevermind,
I'm thinking about the belt of from years of like satellites and so there's that
shit too,
but that there wasn't much of that in 1969.
Not near what it,
what about it?
The van Allen radiation belts is intense ban of radiation for miles that,
that surrounds the earth that you would have to go through to get to the moon.
They apparently though there's a hole that you could go through in the top with
the radiation belt,
isn't there?
But the idea is that there was no shielding to protect them from radiation.
They just weren't in this aluminum tin.
Can you,
or touch or lunar module,
like they have a,
there was a science exhibit I went to once that had,
um,
a,
a replica of the lunar module and you can put your hands on it and it's like,
Whoa,
this thing is,
oh,
really?
Meda coke cans.
And it's like,
it's nothing so weird looking.
There's also like photographs that are fucking wanky lights that go at two
different angles and they say,
well,
that's possible due to,
you know,
uh,
uneven terrain and,
you know,
things reflecting off of things,
all these different variables.